نعود مره ثانيه الى الحديث لكن هذه المره
اقتصادي الدفع اقتصاديه توقعتها مطاعم
ومحال في بريطانيا في يوم تتويج الملك
الجديد تشارلز الثالث هذه الدفعه قد لا
تحل مشاكل المملكه التي تعاني من ازمات
اقتصاديه مرعبه تزيدها فكره يوم عطله اخر
بمناسبه هذا التجويج كل هذا ياتي مع
تكاليف اللي تتحمل الحكومه احتفالا
بالتتويج طبعا كل هذا يحصل اصلا في وسط
اقتصاد مشاهدينا في بريطانيا يعاني من
الاضرابات والتضخم المرتفع وانخفاض ايضا
في مستوى المعيشه من المتوقع ان يتقلص
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي في المملكه
المتحده بنسبه 0.3% هذا العام مسجلا اسوا
اداء لاي دوله متقدمه وفقا للصندوق النقد
الدولي فراح نشوف هلا كيف ينعكس هذا
التتويج اقتصاديا على بريطانيا في هذه
الظروف وال اجابه راح تكون في فقره الجانب
الاقتصادي مع الزميله سمر الموسطه
طيب هنا معنا سمر صباح الخير
شكرا جزيلا سمر دائما كان في حديث بانه
التتويج هذا هو ارهاق للميزانيه المرهقه
اصلا البريطانيه فبالتالي كيف ستتعامل معه
بالفعل كلف اكثر من مليارين دولار
الارقام في اختلافات في اختلاف
ات
بهاي الظروف الصعبه
الارقام لحد الان هم ما تكلموا عن الارقام
المفروض يعلنون عنها قريبا
توقعات تشير انه قد يصل الى مئه مليون
دولار واكبر التكاليف كانت تكاليف
السكيوريتي او
الاب يعني هذه من اكبر البريطانيه استفادت
كمان من هذا التتويج او من المفترض انها
تستفيد اقتصاديا ايضا
الاستفاده اللي صارت طبعا المطاعم استفادت
تقريبا يقال انه المطاعم والسياحه تشير
التوقعات قد تستفيد الى مليار ونصف
المليار دولار من العطله اللي كانت ثلاث
ايام ايضا المحل التجاريه كلها باعت
التسوق يعني خصوصا تنتشر في هذه الفتره
بيع هذول التدبير الدببه اللي لابس العلم
علب البسكتس اللي عليهم صور الملك على
فكره انه هذا للكورنيش
ذات خلال هذا الاسبوع قبل هاي تقع تحت فئه
القروسري التسوق يعني المواد الغذائيه
زادت تقريبا 100 مليون دولار خلال هذا
الاسبوع عن الاسابيع الفائته بس العطله
الاضافيه اللي صارت الاثنين اللي سموها
البنك هوليدي التعطر عن العمل والانتاجيه
تكلف الاقتصاد بحسب بيت دبليو سي الاقتصاد
البريطاني او كلفت يوم ما توفت الملكه
وصار في عطله زياده كلفت اكثر من مليار
دولار فقد تكون التكلفه مماثله بسبب
التوقف عن الانتاجيه في العمله يعني
الحكومه كيف ستعوض ذلك اللي
صارت السياحه تقريبا مثل ما قلنا والمطاعم
حتست
فاد
النقل المنيع اكيد اللي صار المنتجات اللي
بنفس الوقت هو من الجدير ذكره انه تكاليف
تتويج مالكه اليزابيث قبل 70 عاما تحديدا
كان في
1953 كلفت نص المبلغ اللي كلفته اذا
حسبناه
للطبخ ايه
25 مليون يمكن بس اذا اضفتيه للتضخم وهاي
الاشياء حيصير تقريبا 50 مليون دولار
واللي هو نصف اللي كلف هذا الكورنيشن
الحالي الدنيا صايره غاليه نار لانه
ههه بالتاكيد ان شاء الله سون بلكي ترجع
الامور الى مجرىها ان شاء الله شكرا شكرا
كثير الك سمر الماشطه شكرا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات